letterboxed is a social platform that
allegedly allows users to post and share
their opinions about movies whether new
or old however social media users
noticed that something was radically
different about the review list for what
is a woman
so letterbox has hidden all reviews and
ratings of the movie from public view on
the reviews of page for what is a woman
you're only allowed to
view the star ratings people have given
the film but you're not allowed to read
the reviews of the movie unless you go
directly to the user's page and read the
review every other movie on the site has
the listed ratings page recent reviews
and popular reviews shown without
restriction this is just
it's just i mean it's remarkable isn't
it
they are so terrified of this movie
they're going this far out of their way
to make sure that you can't talk about
it
censoring the review the user reviews of
the movie that's how afraid they are of
this film it is really incredible
and if you haven't watched the movie yet
and subscribe to what to dailywire and
or go to what is woman.com and subscribe
to watch the movie this is all the more
reason why you ought to do that